in energy producing states as he said
pennsylvania and texas and
where polls show close races cbs news
political contributors that's terry
sullivan and jamal simmons join us now
terry managed senator rubio marco
rubio's campaign back in 2016
and jamal worked for president bill
clinton he was also an advisor for
president barack obama's
2008 campaign very busy busy gentleman
we thank you guys for joining us this
morning
because it was a real debate a real
conversation good morning to you both
and i think voters got to see real
differences so jamal i want to start
with you because both camps are saying
today
my guy had a great night can both be
true
both could be true because i think
they're talking to very different parts
of the american population
okay well you know they're talking to
very different parts of the american
population right
so vice president biden is trying to
appeal to these sort of suburban
women who are you know feeling very
anxious about the level of rancor that's
occurring in this society
donald trump's trying to encourage his
voters to show up and turn out we're
seeing some success with that some of
the non-college white voters we're
seeing starting to search
in some of these states i'm hearing from
a lot of analysts but you know i think
last night president trump
he surrendered to the politics on style
but he resisted when it came to
substance he never did offer a plan
about how he was going to try to help
solve the coronavirus
even though he seemed like he was trying
to perform very well in terms of the
style of the debate
and joe biden jamal
oh and i think joe biden did what it
yeah joe biden did what it is he needed
to do
um he was out there and he really just
you know he presented his case
and that was the case the american
public wanted to hear that he could be
the one
who had a plan for the american public
and not
get into some of those big fights that
donald trump likes to get into including
about their kids
when joe biden didn't attack any of
trump's kids even though trump kept
attacking hunter
hey terry do you think the muted
microphone listen first let's give a
shout out to kristen welker i thought
she guided it beautifully along
do you think the muted mic made a
difference for either candidate
you know you know i maybe the the
prospect of being muted made a
difference because clearly it was a very
different debate
than it was a few weeks ago but it
didn't appear that it was used very
often if at all
and so one way or the other this was the
debate
that donald trump needed the best
possible outcome for him
if it's if it's enough at this point i
don't know but if this was the donald
trump
who'd been campaigning the last six
months i think we'd be looking at
extremely different race
he really prosecuted the case against
joe biden and against joe biden's
policies
in a very effective way and it was a
strong performance for him last night
but he keeps saying terry that the
coronavirus is winding down and he
and he keeps saying it's winding down
while the death toll keeps climbing
do you think that's an effective
strategy because it simply isn't true
that the coronavirus is
winding down or that you don't need to
worry about it and don't
let it dominate your life that's just
not true
well look uh here's what is true that
there are
facts and figures that show that the
death rate is going down the mortality
rate is going down there are positive
things
that we're seeing with the coronavirus
and it and we can't live our life in
fear
and look i can't defend or and won't try
to defend different things that donald
trump says
about the ground of virus but the facts
are that it is
less lethal in the united states than it
once was
and that's a good thing and we should we
should be covering that we should be
reporting it and we shouldn't be
just living out of pure fear all the
time there are parts of the economy that
we have to open
we do need to have schools reopened we
need
to to learn how to live with this awful
terrible virus
in the best way possible you know jamal
the president gail we've
i was gonna say you know we've been
through this before as a country in 1968
there are about 17 000 americans who
died in the vietnam war there were riots
and
and protests that were taking place
across the country and lyndon johnson
decided not to run for president that
was the case
i think that uh joe biden was trying to
get to last night anybody who's presided
over a situation where 220
000 americans have died and he doesn't
have a plan to get us out of that to
stop it like lyndon johnson didn't have
a plan to get us out of the vietnam war
it's time for him to step down i think
the president likes it compared to 1968
he thinks he's richard nixon law and
order it might be that he'll he's lbj
and his time has passed
he also says that he's done more for
black america than any president other
than abraham lincoln speaking of lbj
should we should maybe lbj be included
in that that civil rights voting act
back in 1964
seem to be quite helpful to your people
jamal
i think there are a few presidents who
might make the cut so what did you think
what did you think when he said that
you know i thought it was something
ridiculous and you know we heard joe
biden
at one point he says oh god over the
force of the microphone
um which is another quote that we will
last i think in infamy
um you know when we when we hear that
kind of thing it just goes to the core
point of the trump presidency
which is that it seems like he says the
things that he thinks are good for him
politically
but not necessarily the things that are
that are appropriate or good for the
american family
and that's the point that i think
americans are really ready to get past
is let's find somebody who can bring the
country together and not just somebody
who's going to keep dividing it
so terry final word from you 50 million
people they say close to 50 have already
voted in this race what does each person
need to do in the final stretch
it's 11 days terry and counting
you know donald trump needs to keep
prosecuting the case against joe biden
that he's going to raise taxes
and that that president trump won't that
he's better for the economy
and that that he's going to return
america to uh to
being a little bit more normal sooner
and and that's the same thing that joe
biden does in a different way
is that he needs to continue to show
that look if you're tired of this
if you're tired of the way things are
i'm the change you need and
you know both of them have that same
thing all right terry sullivan and jamal
simmons i know we'll see you again
in the next 11 days thank you gail i
trimmed my beard for you
i noticed i noticed but i wasn't going
to say anything but i definitely noticed
all right thanks guys just for you thank
you thank you i'm going to